whenever someone whenever someone starts
using personal names and screaming like
a lunatic they're losing the debate
Rabbi schmi B he's he's a rabbi who goes
on in television and and defends Jews
and Israel I suppose uh he gave a real
lesson to Jank yuger about the history
of the Middle East Jank was screaming
and screaming and screaming we're going
to start with then uh the rabbi
explaining a little bit of history and
just watch Jen's reaction I've spent
I've spent my life debating people
whenever someone whenever someone starts
using personal names and screaming like
a lunatic they're losing the debate let
me Remain
thean palan the Palestinians the the
Palestinians were offered to state in
1936 in the appeal commission they
rejected it they were offered to state
in 1947 the UN partition plan they
in 1967 after Israel conquered Judean
Samaria in the West Bank they rejected
it they were offered to state in 200000
yaser arat a Barack they rejected it
they were offered a state with awod Omar
2008 they rejected it they have the
Israel unilaterally withdrew from Gaza
in 2005 and they did not create a state
in fact where were you chank when you
say that you care about Palestinian
children when Hamas stole the highest
rate of per capita International foreign
aid larger than the Marshall Plan from
Palestinian children did not build
schools for them did not build hospitals
took all the money to buy bombs and to
build a network of tunnels which is
larger than the than the New York Subway
system where were you then why did you
come up now in fact when Bashar Al Assad
killed
600,000 children Arab children when he
gassed them with mustard gas my
organization took out full page New York
Times ads to protect them from sarin gas
where are you then you don't care about
Arab children you are a Jew hater
defined as someone who only wants to lie
and say that the Jews are genocide and
don't try to cancel me and say that I
shouldn't be on say you know I'm a
little conflicted not not just cuz for
the first time in all the years as I
showed a video of him but you know in
some ways I I owe Jen a certain amount
of credit because if it wasn't for
seeeing his endless screaming and lack
of knowledge and historical knowledge
and actually his true bigotry and all of
those things I don't know that I ever
would have really woken up to what the
left was so I don't regret working there
as embarrassing as it is I suppose in
some level in retrospect that I had
anything to do with those people by the
way the name The Young Turks which is
the name of the network those were the
group groups of people in Turkey who
committed the Armenian Genocide Comm
killed over a million Armenians this is
pre-World War I I think it was what was
it around 1910 if I'm not mistaken and
Hitler got the idea of the Holocaust
from The Young Turks who were committing
a genocide against the Armenians because
the world didn't care about that so then
Hitler was like oh I guess I could
probably pull this off because the world
won't care about that so Jen literally
named his organization after uh an
organization that was for a genocide
that committed a genocide which if I'm
not mistaken he still denies and then of
course he calls the rabbi a racist and a
bigot and the rest of it uh but
everything and I and I would welcome you
to fact check it everything that the
rabbi said there was true that the 1936
peel commission by the way you could
watch my interview with RFK he goes into
all the history too 1947 partition plan
67 after that War uh 2000 2008 there
were so many times that the Palestinians
could have had a state it would have
been the first time they had estate
because there's never been a Palestinian
State the only people to ever offer the
Palestinians estate are the Israelis
these are the facts and that's why they
can be laid out calmly and cleanly
without screaming and without calling
everyone a
racist